on se repose où on prend encore un film
difficile reprendre les étoiles on prend
quoi il faut prendre la guerre des
étoiles
oui la cabine tout d'abord alors la
guerre des étoiles fils de george lucas
allez-y alors prenons le penser que vous
avez encore anguélos poulos qui est
angoissant
regardons le pour la bonne bouche oui et
crazy horse pour la bouche amusante
n'oubliez pas sur clémence de belles
manque que j'aime en skate avouent-ils
alesi la guerre des étoiles george lucas
qui commence jean louis être rapide vous
voulez voici ce à dire que c'est le
genre de film pour lequel il faut se
refaire une âme d'enfant toute fraîche
se passe quoi nous réussissons très bien
toi moi je réagis très très bien se voir
genre de film est la seule loi j'adore
les bandes dessinées ai dit que je vois
comme ça du robot extrêmement marrant et
qui tombent amoureux l'un des autres je
trouve ça très bien
alors la guerre des étoiles c'est une
énorme machine à l'américaine avec alors
naturellement dans la pub on vous donne
tout de suite le le nombre de milliers
de dollars que ça à côté c'est visible
sur l'écran ce que déjà rassurant et
puis ensuite bon bah il faut se laisser
aller dans une espèce d'énorme machine
remarquablement bien fait
on commence par s'amusait beaucoup me
dire que je me suis amusé énormément et
lorsqu'on réfléchit on finit par y
trouver tout même des tas de choses
d'abord ce qui m'a intéressé c'est la
reconduction comme je m'intéresse
beaucoup aux romans populaires romans de
chevalerie et ses devoirs qu'on a pris
tous les ingrédients de la littérature
chevaleresque de la littérature
populaire et qu'on les a transplanté
naturellement dans le monde de la
science fiction c'est à dire qu'il ya le
bon et le méchant le méchant et qu'elle
représentait naturellement par un
personnage de ça se passe naturellement
plein galaxie bien sûr entre vénus
saturne mercure ira beaucoup plus loin
encore beaucoup plus loin des millions
aux entreprises à des films sur la
science bon et alors vous avez par
exemple le château le château noir du
chevalier noir c'est une planète
maléfique dans laquelle naturellement le
héros blanc n'a essayé de s'introduire
vous avez ce qui soutient le côté blanc
naturellement l'héroïne centrale qu est
une
c'est ce qui fera toutes trois vertus
naturellement pas tellement lointaine à
lloris elle se rapproche des beats
terrible numéro vert alors la prévoir
comment alors bon tout ça tout ça veut
dire que l'on joue le jeu et faut jouer
le jeu
il y à un duel fantastique de durandal
organisé p naturellement c'est des
rayons laser société du nez on sait où
elles sont simplement dus mais voilà on
vous appelle un exemple d'une homme qui
n'est pas frêche c'est marrant ça qu'ils
voient du néo alors qu'il faut voir du
un laser moi j'ai eu à laser c'est un
laser hop on se bat avec des rayons
laser
oui avec des rayons de bonneuil ont les
meilleurs laser et dont il faut marcher
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir qu'il ya deux trois petites idées
parce que le monsieur le cas ce qu'a
fait ça n'est pas un imbécile et ce qui
en fait le scénario ne sont pas du tout
des abc ce qui est amusant c'est de voir
comment il reprend les idées
si vous voulez des idées force
aujourd'hui par exemple une espèce
d'écologie sidéral qui est assez
marrante
parce que le jeu heroes c'est une espèce
de fermiers de fermiers macrobiotique
c'est comme ça qu'on dit oui dans un
truc dans une ferme complètement bidon
que dans un désert extraordinaire tous
avec déjà des gadgets fenomeno alors
déjà ce jeune fermier va naturellement
08 juillet c'est gros comme une maison
gros commun une fusée à terre spatiale
et il va tomber la princesse et rubans
ils ont adoré des tas d'enfants qui sont
tous galactique
et puis il ya aussi d'autres
un autre truc est intéressant c'est que
deux idées sont intéressantes
une carafe 30 et l'autre qui est
inquiétante l'idée rassurante
c'est que les machines peuvent se
détraquer bon stanley kubrick l'avait
sublimement utilisé dans ce dossier
il écrase haut débit je viens aussi
l'écraser c'est d'abord cette oeuvre qui
est interdit c'est 2000-2001 gros là là
c'est bon si c'est vrai c'est là c'est
le tout-venant c'est beaucoup beaucoup
plus qui se limite dans ses ambitions
c'est pas du tout stanley kubrick bien
sûr mais c'est cette idée que un robot
peut finir par être plus humain qu'un
homme dans la mesure où il se détraque
et s'est représenté ci voulait d'une
façon très marrante par deux robots un
grand à petit c'est une espèce de laurel
et hardy le cosmos et qui sont amies
copines c'est un question tombés
amoureux l'un de l'autre y en a qui veut
dire ce que je vous prête mes circuits
magnétise etc
ne voulez-vous pas me toucher village du
travail et puis ya eu une autre idée est
l'outil des quais mois rassurante parce
que ça frôle il est noté nick et moi
rassurante c'est que et c'est là ça
c'est le genre qui m'inquiète c'est que
d'après ces messieurs il y a on va vers
un monde qui est terriblement fasciste
c'est à dire qu'il ya un fascisme noir
que représenté par les villas le
chevalier qui de coiffer comme une
espèce de samouraï dans son château dans
sa planète forte c'est le fascisme noir
mais qui évacuent par une espèce
d'autres fasciste le tas fascisme blanc
là je suis pas de ceux là ça commence à
m'inquiéter c'est à dire que la
cérémonie finale si marc barrât te
rappelle bien c'est nuremberg si vous
voulez en matière plastique blanches si
je mets pas du tout quoi jeremy jay
perez
je peux plus au nord six mois
sensibiliser mais oui mais c'est bien
ces deux images à pédales 14 cognac
toute une foule marche au pas cadencé
n'aurait des gestes comme ça et portent
le même uniforme
moi je flippe
c'était ça merci jean louis michel pérez
a vu quoi là bas je veux samedi le jour
alors la guerre des étoiles
fabriqué à partir dont la tradition
chevaleresque dont par le bruit tout ça
va ça sorte de bande dessinée américains
et ça sorte de bande dessinée comme
prince vaillant particulier c'est bien
celle à partir de passes vaillant s'est
fabriqué le pictural flash gordon sa de
l'aveu même de georges le casque est un
grand amateur de ces bandes dessinées et
de ses films qui ont été faits dans les
années trente à laâyoune hivernale s'est
fabriqué aussi à partir de tous les
spectacles les spectacles télévisés
qu'on peut donner
depuis des années aux jeunes américains
et à savoir les séries qui sont faites
directement pour la télévision et aussi
tous les films hollywoodiens proches qui
sont des anciens films et qui dont les
droits ont été acquis par la télévision
américaine et qui passe là bas presque
24 heures sur 24
d'où le fait que la guerre des étoiles
est construite la plupart du temps comme
un film de guerre de la seconde guerre
mondiale avec l'opposition lutte contre
le totalitarisme en faveur de la
démocratie
mais oui il a raison j'ai fait là dessus
les plus démunis à d'ailleurs toute la
fin du film est fait a été longuement
étudié d'après des films des combats
aériens de la seconde guerre mondiale
j'ai cru revoir les messerschmitt est
absolument ces avions américains ce
n'est pas un mystère féminin gars se dit
d'autre part une chose qui est très
importante il faut voir comment le
public américain qui fait un succès
énorme à la guerre des étoiles c'est un
des plus grands voiles film et quel est
le public le public a généralement n'a
pas plus de 20 ans le gros du public ce
sont des adolescents qui voit le film
avec le rejoint leurs cigarettes de
marijuana en poche car dans la plupart
des grandes salles américaines irs plus
tellement de problèmes maintenant peu de
gens peuvent tirer leurs cigares de
maroilles piscine et y voit le film de
cette façon là ce film c'est un film
planant ça ressemble c'était comme une
espèce d'énorme machine psychédélique
comme dans les années 60 dans les années
60 qui avaient tous ces spectacles c'est
light chose ces trucs de lui
hier et c'est qui est fait pour être vu
dans des discothèques dans des choses
comme ça or la guerre des étoiles
maintenant c'est une espèce de gros
spectacles cinématographiques fait à
partir de ce principe là c'est peut-être
pas voulu au départ mais c'est comme ça
que c'est utilisé maintenant et c'est un
film qui joue uniquement sur les effets
visuels
c'est absolument prodigieux et tout à
l'heure quand on parlait du montage de
documents il était une fois l'amérique
c'est je crois qu'on peut rapprocher il
était une fois l'amérique et la voc des
grands documents des grandes montage de
documents et de films hollywoodiens et
qui a le court maintenant aux états unis
tous et tous ces montages sont faits sur
des scènes chocs qui sont autant
d'effets visuels un bombardement visuel
continue mal et qui bien sûr ne renvoie
aucune espèce de réflexion possible ou
imagina bien aucun point de vue critique
absolument rien et les grands films
américains
quand je parle de grands films je parle
des films extrêmement diffusé qui ont
coûté très cher et c'est que ce soit la
guerre des étoiles que ce soit les
grands fonds mais ça c'est parfaitement
des villes les grands fonds bien sûr que
le sujet de la guerre des étoiles et
plus astucieux et grands freins mais je
voulais je leur approche parce que ce
sont des films qui sont faits uniquement
sur l'impact physique et sur le pouvoir
visuel qu'ils ont sur les gens c'est
pour ça que je les mette dans les
catégories de delphine planant ce sont
des films qui sont techniquement
extraordinairement bien fait et plus
sera plus et oui mr michel c'est là je
n'avais parfait tu apportes drôlement
doit le mouv à mon moulin parce que
toute la cérémonie finale en effet août
tunisie ou cassent les pièces et mus
libéré très important non mauvais en lui
en trente secondes les usines celle des
remises martial de lohengrin une annexe
à tirer bat waldner
je voulais dire par là que ces films là
était peut-être un peu dangereux enfin
dangereux pas d'un point de vue moral
mais peut-être d'un point de vue
politique parce que ce sont des choses
qui sont décrites et des objets de
consommation le film devient de plus en
plus un objet de consommation de
l'abrutissement total les abrutissement
total et aucune réflexion n'est possible
à partir de ce genre de film cela dit ce
sont des films qui sont extrêmement
agréable à voir et à lire des étoiles
c'est absolument
jean tutu en train de conseiller aux
gens d'aller prendre leur pied là-bas
c'est à dire qu'il faut il faut que les
jambes étaient de leurs conseillers oui
mais c'est agréable dagahaley avec la
france était déjà si la salle si la
salle est éclaté en applaudissements à
la fin siens à paris marie grandes
salles parisiennes archi bourré avec des
queues de 150 m c'était quand même une
réseau s'est passé gamme très bien un
jour ton point de vue mais évidemment il
faut appliquer tout esprit critique
c'est complètement débile disent voilà
bon c'est complètement séparé s'est pas
complètement absolument pas parce que
c'est le travail et une perverse
débilité voilà non perez a dit
exactement tout ce qu'il fallait dire et
je ne devrais pas trouvé un mot
simplement je dis en mieux ça m'arrange
alec guiness jouant les père noël avec
une grande barbe blanche et jouant les
purs esprits devant la maléfique et
toile noire
moi ça me fait marrer mais je reconnais
que devant une salle emporté par un
délire d' enthousiasme je me laisse
emporter moi aussi
merci
[Musique]